[Applauso]
allora io mi occupo di innovazione che
significa aiutare le aziende in un
momento molto delicato che è quello di
costruire una cultura un commitment del
cambiamento allora una cosa che mi ha
sempre affascinato cercare immaginare di
capire quali sono gli ambienti che
aiutano le aziende a fare questo quindi
a creare quella cultura e soprattutto
cercare di immaginare come sarà fatto il
mondo del lavoro dei prossimi anni
allora per per iniziare da lì quindi che
momento stiamo vivendo e come si
cambierà
vi porto per un momento in florida io
abito lì abito a miami e c'è un posto
molto affascinante a tre ore di macchina
a nord di miami si chiama che canaveral
e la base spaziale americana ha posto da
qui vengano fatti tutti i lanci spaziali
allora perché è un posto affascinante
perché se voi ci pensate negli anni 60
c'è stato un momento incredibile per
l'umanità in cui noi abbiamo avuto una
fiducia tale verso la tecnologia che ci
ha fatto dire possiamo apprendere andare
a mettere i piedi sulla luna io poi
penso che questa fotografia sia reale
allora
sono tornato pochi mesi fa hanno
accompagnato un amico ed è cambiato
tutto
c'è un posto in cui tutta la narrativa
era concentrata sul passato quindi
qualcosa che è successo indicativamente
tra gli anni 60 agli anni 90
ora è tutta spostata sul futuro quindi
se voi oggi andata che cana bravi
parleranno di marte come noi diventeremo
una specie multi planetaria come
costruiremo delle basi su marte o come
fra pochi anni sembrano veramente di 23
anni magari parleremo un biglietto
esattamente con biglietto dell'aereo per
fare un viaggio nello spazio e quindi
avere la possibilità di vedere il nostro
pianeta da un punto di vista che ad oggi
a beneficio di veramente pochissimi
allora torniamo indietro e per capire
dove ci troviamo oggi faccio di nuovo un
passo di 50 anni indietro e tornò nel
1964 allora sottoscritto un trattato da
ufficio e si chiamava alvin toffler che
fece una fotografia dello stato
psicologico della comunità della
socialità americana di quel momento e
l'aveva chiamato the feature choc
cioè lui diceva gli americani in questo
momento sono scioccati dal futuro 1964
allora qual era il problema non lo
individuava sostanzialmente due il primo
over lo dove information c'è troppa
informazione le persone riescono più a
processare tutta l'informazione che
ricevono secondo problema accelerazione
tecnologica
l'accelerazione è tale da dare a quasi
un disagio fisico
allora provate a pensarci non sembra
molto lontano dal momento che stiamo
vivendo noi adesso a 7.000 capi di
impresa poco tempo fa qualche mese fa
stato chiesto come avverto nel momento
in cui stanno vivendo il 95 per cento ha
detto siamo in un momento iper
accelerato e harvard business review di
nuovo pochi mesi fa ha stimato il
problema che stiamo vivendo noi oggi
dell'over lodovini formation in qualcosa
che pesa nel governo americano le
l'economia americana quasi un trilione
di dollari all'ora non so se qualcuno ha
già fatto l'uno più uno però cosa unisce
no questi due momenti terza rivoluzione
industriale anni 60 oggi siamo nel pieno
della quarta rivoluzione industriale
l'unica vera differenza sono le
tecnologie al tempo erano i primi
computer erano i primi esperimenti di
robotica
da lì è nato tutto il mondo della
science fiction che viviamo ancora oggi
da lì la gente comincia a chiedersi ma
come cambierà il lavoro
cambieranno le fabbriche come cambierà
la mia famiglia
oggi le tecnologie sono diverse sono
queste quindi piattaforme di connessione
praticamente infinita intelligenze
artificiali nuovi sistemi di
computazione computazione quantica del
quale è veramente oggi ancora non
riusciamo a capire le dimensioni e la
potenza allora è evidente che noi stiamo
vivendo come tutte le rivoluzioni
industriali in un momento di grande
incertezza
la buona notizia che ci hanno già
passati quindi supereremo anche questo
allora che cosa significa per otto non
dal tema principale lavorare in un
momento in cui c'è grande incertezza
allora il world economic forum ha
individuato fa sempre delle classifiche
per dire quali sono le skills che in
questo momento sembrano più importanti
da sviluppare all'interno delle
organizzazioni e quale che quelle che
perdono traccia
allora in questo momento sembra che le
cose più importanti non siano più la
pianificazione strategica
il management e la coordinazione il
controllo ma diventano molto più
importante tutto quello che ha a che
fare con l'innovazione
l'originalità la creatività il pensiero
critico
questo perché se tu non sai dove andare
se siamo in un momento in cui le cose
cambiano no velocità tale che non si
riesce a prevedere quale sarà il futuro
e ovvio che avere una grande
pianificazione strategica non è il modo
in cui lo riesce ad affrontare
allora c'è stata un'altra fotografia
ascone molto interessante che racconta
quello che stiamo vivendo noi adesso e
come fa un piccolo excursus di come
abbiamo trasformato il nostro modo di
lavorare anche questa è stata fatta
dell'emmeti è un professore che si
chiama 8 charmer e ha raccontato a
questa visione del mondo di oggi
secondo tre disconnessioni allora le tre
disconnessioni sono queste la prima
disconnessione che noi stiamo vivendo la
disconnessione verso la natura
voi pensate ci noi collettivamente
stiamo trattando il nostro pianeta come
personalmente non faremmo mai ma siamo
sempre noi allora in termini lavorativi
noi siamo passati da vivere molto
all'aperto lavorare nei campi ma anche
quando poi e slip siamo passati ai
lavori manuali di diverso tipo no i
mezzi di trasporto erano molti meno e si
andava a piedi se andava in bicicletta
passavamo tanto tempo all'aperto
oggi piano piano ci siamo spostati verso
le città le fabbriche
i grattacieli edifici hanno cominciato a
racchiudere i gli spazi di lavoro
dall'altra parte c'è una disconnessione
verso noi stessi
da dove arriva da arriva da tutto il
mondo dell'efficienza della produttività
sia del lavoro manuale sia da come nato
i primi open space degli anni venti per
essere produttivi per essere efficaci tu
devi essere un pezzo di un grande
meccanismo distacco da noi stessi
la terza disconnessione la
disconnessione verso gli altri e io li
la posizione secondo me quando sono nati
kuby con il chiuderò questo piccolo
spazio che tutti può personalizzare però
che ti distacca dagli altri e che ha
generato un senso di grande competizione
che ancora molto figlio del modo in cui
studiano di cui lavoriamo oggi allora se
ci pensate questa fotografia delle tre
disconnessioni per me è incredibile in
un momento in cui non siamo mai stati
così connessi come lo siamo oggi la
tecnologia ci dà degli strumenti che
fino a pochi anni fa erano impensabili
allora come cambia il mondo del lavoro
in un momento in cui siamo in grande
incertezza ma contemporaneamente abbiamo
tecnologia che ci connette in ogni modo
allora il primo dei fenomeni il più
evidente e chi il lavoro non è più un
concetto locale è diventato un concetto
globale che cosa significa significa
tante cose intanto significa che con un
computer una connessione possa fare il
90 per cento del lavoro che prima invece
devo andare a fare in ufficio ma non
solo per il knowledge worker pensate
anche per i lavori manuali 5g e
piattaforme tecnologiche che vi
raccontavo prima possono permettere un
medico di operare da miami una persona e
un paziente che si trova per esempio a
verona quindi se io sono un imprenditore
grazie alla tecnologia oggi non ho più
bisogno di assumere persone che stanno
anno a pochi chilometri dalla mia sede
principale lo posso fare con persone che
vivono anche molto lontano
secondo concetto è che questa era dall
incertezza cambia anche le
organizzazioni delle aziende significa
che se le aziende sono state costruite
per silos dipartimenti con background
molto simili che lavorano su problemi
specifici oggi nel momento in cui la
complessità dei problemi e così grande e
soprattutto la volatilità dei problemi e
così grande non puoi più affrontarli con
un unico punto di vista lo devi fare con
più punti di vista per cui uno dei temi
principali
il pane in questo momento è quello della
contaminazione come faccio a mettere
insieme risorse con background diversi
il terzo punto è quello di un passaggio
che va dalla competizione alla co
creazione e co creazione immaginate un
senso più ampio possibile non è tanto
solo cooperazione con i colleghi ma
anche con creazioni in tutta la catena
del valore con i propri clienti con i
propri fornitori ma addirittura con i
propri competitor
c'è un tema in marketing schema co
opetition competition significa proprio
questo aziende competitor che per il
bene del proprio mercato lavorano
assieme
allora siamo in un mondo di grande
incertezza cambiano le skills e cambia
il modo in cui l'organizzazione devono
ripensare il modo di lavorare
questo come si riflette su come la gente
soprattutto le nuove generazioni stanno
immaginando di lavorare ora sono due
fenomeni che su scommesso molto
interessante il primo è questa se voi
aprite instagram e scrivete hashtag
office today
quindi questo il mio ufficio di oggi
troverete migliaia di fotografie come
queste persone che sono a bordo piscina
vicino al mare dentro un bosco con il
proprio laptop che dice ecco questo è il
mio modo di lavorare di oggi allora li
chiamano nomad worker quindi persone che
col loro computer se ne vanno in giro
scelgono posti molto belli dove gli
piace stare lavorano da lì allora io
penso ovviamente questo modo di fare è
molto tipico delle start up e molto
tipico delle nuove generazioni
soprattutto le aziende tecnologiche ma
se ci pensate perché sono partiti prima
loro ma perchè le start up per
definizione sono abituate a lavorare in
un clima di incertezza la start up è
incertezza allo stato puro allora la
cosa però è secondo me loro hanno capito
l'hanno capita forse prima di noi e
questo c'è un falso mito che quello del
bilanciamento vita lavoro allora
guardate io ho un amico
rischiamo harry con figlio di 7 anni che
un paio di anni fa gli ha detto questo
ora papa
io ho capito che adesso vado a scuola
dopo la scuola vado all'università dopo
l'università c'è il lavoro e poi c'è la
vita
enrico il mio amico se licenziato a tipo
un paio di mesi dopo di questo racconto
e adesso fa il nome di worker allora il
vero senso di questa che non c'è un
bilanciamento vita lavoro e c'è una vita
è una sola e all'interno di questa
l'attività lavorativa deve farne parte
detto questo secondo fenomeno se voi
andate a vedere come si stanno
trasformando gli uffici soprattutto
delle aziende più tecnologiche vi
renderete conto che hanno cominciato a
simulare gli ambienti dove la prima
categoria va a lavorare allora gli
uffici cominciano ad assomigliare a
delle caffetterie cominciano ad
assomigliare a dei living room dei
salotti
se tu vai a chiedere che cosa i
dipendenti voglio in un'azienda alla
fine la prima cosa è strano 57 per cento
questa è stata una banca americana che
ha fatto questo sondaggio dice voglio
aria pulita
voglio luce naturale voglio posti che mi
aiutano a ispirare la mia creatività
voglio degli spazi di collaborazione
questo ha portato per esempio anche ad
avere natura che comincia ad entrare
all'interno degli uffici fino secondo me
è un piccolo estremo che è sono le
policy per poter portare i propri
animali in ufficio allora io capisco
tutti i benefici del fatto di portarsi
il proprio cane in ufficio però secondo
me nessuno ha mai fatto un sondaggio per
chiedere ai cani se effettivamente fa
piacere farr 40 ore alla settimana
bene detto questo perché ci sono questi
fenomeni
ma perché nell'era dell'incertezza il
valore principale si sviluppa nel
momento in cui sviluppa la creatività e
sviluppi l'intuizione delle proprie
organizzazioni
allora più o meno tre anni fa con una
serie di amici abbiamo cominciato a
ragionare se potevamo dare un contributo
a questo tipo di mondo e quindi provare
a immaginare un ufficio ha fatto per
l'era dell'incertezza
allora il primo punto principale da cui
siamo partiti e di chiederci ma abbiamo
veramente bisogno di pareti possiamo
fare un ufficio che sia molto più vicino
alla natura e che ci riconnetta con
quella natura con cui ci siamo
disconnessi possiamo immaginarci un
ufficio che dia spazio all'ispirazione
guardate oggi ancora oggi le pratiche
lavorative sono viste come lavoro al
computer faccio le riunioni lui
ma il lavoro è un processo molto più
lungo le attività sono molto più
complesse
il punto iniziale l'ispirazione se oggi
una persona in ufficio guarda per aria
per 5 minuti una persona che non sta
producendo ma è lì e lì che si sviluppa
l'intuizione lì che si sviluppa la
creatività per cui se si parte dall
intuizione il processo poi deve portare
alla contaminazione come faccio a fare
in modo che le persone possano stare
insieme come faccio a creare intimità
dei miei team dei miei spazi fargli
capire e aiutarli a creare degli spazi
modi possono rendersi conto del perché
stanno facendo quello che stanno facendo
co creazione spazi che aiutino le
persone a lavorare insieme e solo alla
fine di tutto questo processo anche
degli spazi in cui in mezzo alla natura
uno possa essere produttivo e rilassato
allora quando abbiamo cominciato a
ragionare su questo
un'ispirazione visiva che ci piaceva era
quella che veniva dai giardini
rinascimentali giardini all'italiana
cioè questi spazi in cui la natura
veniva controllata creavano dei posti
meravigliosi per fare networking abbiamo
visti mille film passeggiate ispirazioni
letture chiacchierate conclusioni di
deal di contratti
ecco siamo partiti da qua e questo è
l'ufficio che non ci siamo immaginati
a questo punto un ufficio che nasce da
tanti piccoli moduli che corrispondono
alle tante nuove tipologie dinamiche di
lavoro di cui abbiamo bisogno oggi però
che sia un ufficio che possa essere
dematerializzato cioè non sono più io
che devo andare in un posto per lavorare
ma l'ufficio agli spazi lavorativi
devono venire dove a me piace stare
ovunque dove mi piace stare bene chiudo
dicendo vi questo cito uno dei miei più
grandi guru mia mamma annamaria quando
ero piccolo mio nonno mi diceva vai
fuori a giocare allora penso che punto
iniziale è che non mi vuole ha tra i
piedi però distinto tutti noi genitori
sappiamo che ai bambini fa bene stare
fuori fa bene a stare all'aria aperta fa
bene stare in mezzo alla natura per poi
è successo qualcosa noi passiamo più del
90 per cento il nostro tempo in spazi
chiusi
allora il mio invito per voi andate a
lavorare fuori
io vi assicuro che starete meglio sarete
meno stressati probabilmente sarete più
intuitivi sarete più creativi ma c'è una
cosa che vi posso garantire è che di
sicuro i vostri cani saranno molto più
felici di seguirvi in ufficio
grazie a tutti grazie